你现在压力很大
第一句开口就要哭了
好恐怖啊
英文不善
女子战队战胜必胜战
全场嗨爆
必须唱
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ I'm ready ♪
♪ Oh i'm ready ♪
♪ One two ready go ♪
这次的嘉宾两位嘉宾都是有义气
真的是很感谢他们两位两日限定组合
他快到了广
再多练一遍
快好7分钟左右好
77分钟吗
可以练两遍
让我们欢迎亚洲碧昂斯
你这好嗨呀
这家气氛好好哦
他参赞我们气氛很好
情绪价值拉满哦
待会要哭哦
第一句开口就要哭了
♪ 我太心 ♪
♪ 那离开的远方 ♪
♪ 不用开 ♪
♪ 也许不 ♪
有一种故事是笑着离以后的思念却背对背
♪ 迷失所有 ♪
而剩下倔强一张没弄到
他感觉有点满意
天哪怎么不悲伤啊
再一次吗
好认真的一次啦
好认真一次
那不能笑的哦
不能笑
就算我怎么样
你都要我吗哈大挑战下来留下来留下来
等一下他这个嘉宾会不会太累
他要唱两首歌
明天还要留下来
那是不是干脆明天一起唱一下
那个恋人未满
我跟你讲
如果我真的留下来
那场面真的很无法控制
第一次吧
偶像好像第一次嘉宾有唱两首歌的
因为我觉得蛮好玩的
没有这样子过
因为那时候跟他吃饭的时候
跟他提的时候
我说哎呀
这个很像我的风格诶
就以为我已经回去了
没有没有没有
我一直都在
♪ Oh baby ♪
♪ 情话多说一点 ♪
♪ 想我就多看一眼 ♪
♪ 表现多一点点 ♪
让我能真的看见你有睡好吗
还韩哥辛苦了
我昨天那个结束之后有讯息
然后我知道他到了
我都没看到
我是早上才看到
因为他睡得很嗨
你知道我生孩子时
他帮我拍
真的还是拍在第一现场摇摆
好亲密哦
记录我那里所有的细节
好以后如果你要生的话
也可以请他
不是因为你是在那个水里面生啊
对对对
要为以后我要生
我现在都几岁了
哈哈很难说
我跟你讲是吗
不要跟命运躲
我跟你讲哪一天啊
明年还跟我说
你要这么讲
对难讲哦
难讲哦
啊昨天怎样
阿林阴魂不散了
上来两次
我觉得蛮好笑的
真的真的蛮好笑的
他很认真的
他是连换一套衣服换两套
我就想说哇他也太用心了吧
韩立可爱唱歌最最最忙嘉宾
他说不定等下等下就出现
真的像上次讲的一样
就出现在台下
好恐怖啊
英魂不散女士
昨天阿丽说哎气氛好好哦
我说我们都是这样啊
这样很好啊
对但是当然也是因为有你们来才会这样啊
他们已经很久没有在台下这给我哎
平常他们已经去后面休息啊
很久没有了哦
没有关系了
在下面挂心啊
赛罗没关系没关系
只是因为ELLA姐的这个哈欠欠教训阿恰恰呵
为什么让的我只看你干哈呢
哈哈心里面明明都有感觉
我要讲为什么不敢面对
♪ 再向前一点点 ♪
♪ 我就会再冲动一点点 ♪
♪ 我就不闪 ♪
♪ 躲不过三个字 ♪
♪ 别犹豫这么久 ♪
♪ 只要你说出口 ♪
你就能拥有我
我想问一下
我对你的感觉好好OK什么感觉
哎呀好紧张啊
屁股夹紧一点
准备好啊
屁股沟开始流汗
是不是可以聊一下那个阿令
昨天就是厚脸皮死不肯下场
小心阿in
等下可能还会介绍他
应该不会上台
他只会来
他对对
因为今天晚上有庆功宴
他可能已经在庆功宴等就开喝了
哈哈乱开他玩笑
拜拜好
谢谢了
那对好
我们现在先不动
晚上晚上会哈哈哈哈哈哈
好妖力好妖力
好妖力
不要让他消失
不要让我消失了
拜拜
♪ Oh bye ♪
♪ 少说一点 ♪
想陪你不只一天
感觉要掉下去
让我又心甘情愿我爱你
♪ Ho baby ♪
♪ 情话多说一点 ♪
♪ 想我就多看一眼 ♪
♪ 表现多一点点 ♪
让我能
我觉得我好闹啊
都来了八首歌
哈哈最爱秀的嘉宾就是我了
太棒了
实现了我的唱跳梦想
到现在还是深深的深深的爱着你
什么心的友情都可以
♪ 有一种悲伤是笑着与你分开 ♪
思念却背对背掌握伤悲伤悲伤
呜呜呜呜呜呜呜
要在我和我
无反应
我和我哈哈哈哈哈哈
再靠近一点点
我就跟你走
再冲动一点点
我就不闪躲